when when Renton discovered x-rays he
was text but when he sent it out to his
politics you he used the picture with it
which was of his wife's hand and all you
could see were her bones and her ring
and these are actually sort of takeoffs
on that that picture came to symbolize
x-rays the hand was easy to x-ray
because it's flat so the Rays passed
through it pretty quickly they didn't
they hadn't quite figured out how to
focus them at that point so they needed
things that weren't very thick being
actually fashionable to have your x-rays
portraits taken of your hand and this is
Tsar Nicholas ii and his wife Alexandra
who summoned a doctor to the Winter
Palace to have their portrait statement
if many of the people who made the
pictures in in the year following x-rays
and medicines were a photographer is
actually because it was pretty easy to
make x-rays by March of 1896 so three
months after their public you could
order a commercial x-ray get an x-ray
czar it's my particular favorite just
because I think the pictures are so what
they chose to x-ray the shoe is
inspected to see the eyelids for the
laces in the hooks and then even the
little safety can probably be holding
his pants pegged closed to think about
you can make photographs of invisible
bones and and this idea that you're
surrounded by this electromagnetic
radiation I mean what's so strange about
thinking there are other invisible
things